the last videos we saw a dominant Persia
have to put down a rebellion by the
Ionians
in the Anatolian Peninsula and they were
really really mad that these Ionians
were helped by the Athenians and the
Eritrea ng's and so Darius the King of
Kings goes off to try to conquer and put
down the Athenians and the Eritrea ins
the first time he sends a fleet in 492
BCE its destroyed by a storm and we'll
see this is not the last time that part
at least part of a Persian fleet is
destroyed by a storm then in 490 he
sends a fleet again and then he is
defeated by the Athenians at marathon
and we saw that right right over there
let me do that in a color you can
actually see but as I mentioned in the
last video the Persians were not done
Darius would not would not live to see
another round with the Greeks but his
successor Xerces would not only try
another attempt but he would amass a
huge huge force against the Greeks - in
his mind finally take them over and he
wants it done so badly that he leads the
forces himself and so we are now 10
years after ten years after the first
Persian invasion we are now at 480 BCE
where Circe's is going to land is going
to try to invade Greece by land and by
sea but as we will see he is also not
going to be successful but this second
invasion is is the stuff of legend and
once again it the the historical
accounts come to us primarily from
Herodotus who was Greek and who was not
a direct observer of this so you might
want to take all of this with a grain of
salt because it does make the Greeks
look awfully good but we do think that
most of this happened but you know it
obviously Herodotus probably added a
little bit of bias there we are likely
to never know so let's think about or
let's see what
xur sees attempt to do so we see this
magenta line this is the line of attack
of Xerces in 480 and you can see there's
one magenta line that is going by see
here and another magenta line that is
going that is going by land and let's
zoom in a little bit more I have another
map here so let's zoom in to this map
right over here that gives us a clearer
picture of what's about to happen in
this next Persian invasion
so just to reorient ourselves here are
the land forces and according to
Herodotus and historians of that time
they numbered this force in them in the
potentially millions of soldiers modern
historians think it was closer to 50,000
to 300,000 we really don't know but we
think it's in the approximately hundred
thousand or a few hundred thousands not
millions but by any measure that is a
huge a huge military force so you know
this is the hundreds of thousands right
over here so hundreds hundreds of
thousands or let me write this one
hundred hundreds of thousands maybe
between 50 and 300,000 they're coming
this way the Persian forces and they
also have a fleet of approximately 1200
1200 ships
now the persians really are not having
good luck with weather whatever they try
to attack greece they face a storm and
about a third of their fleet is
destroyed and so up here they're left
with about and these are all approximate
remember this happened over 2,000 years
ago roughly 2500 years ago so it's
amazing that we know anything about it
at all
but and obviously we have to rely on
Herodotus and and whatever historical
accounts we can find so the Persians are
invading by land and sea and the Greeks
have a strategy of let's try to stop
them by land at Thermopylae and stop
them
by sea at the Strait of Artemisium right
over here
and there's some historical debate of
you know was this a big grand strategy
to eventually try to defeat the Persians
at Salamis which eventually happens or
were they you know genuinely trying to
stop them there and they were because
they couldn't they had to retreat back
to Salamis as we'll see that second
narrative is what actually happens well
I guess in some level both of those
narratives happen that they are able to
at least slow down the Persians at both
of these places and the Persians are
eventually defeated at the Strait of
Salamis now Thermopylae is the stuff of
legends it is if you've ever seen the
movie 300 it is about the the Spartan
the 300 Spartans soldiers led by King
Leonidas along with roughly 7,000 other
Greeks that they're able to collect to
stop the Persians at Thermopylae and
Thermopylae you're in this coastal area
where there's a very limited area for
for the this massive Persian army to be
funneled through and they the Greeks are
trying to stop them at the pass of
Thermopylae and you could see this you
can see that right over there and by
Herodotus accounts they are actually
quite successful of because they're
funneling that Persian army into a very
narrow space
the Spartans along with the other Greeks
are able to push back and you know this
is a massive outnumbering roughly 7,000
versus many tens or hundreds of
thousands but as Herodotus as Herodotus
Herodotus is accounts go there was a
traitor
amongst the Greeks who go to the
Persians and tell it and show them
another way around and show them another
way around and so the Persians are
essentially are able to not only get
around the Greeks but by surrounding
them are able to defeat the Greeks at
Thermopylae and continue their march and
remember they were able to get to
Eritrea before 10 years before but they
really want to seek their revenge on
Athens and they are able to go to Athens
and but by the time they go there they
see that the the town has been for the
most part evacuated that the Athenians
when they saw that the the Persians were
coming they went to
they went to Salamis right over here so
even though Athens was sacked and
destroyed the Athenian people were not
destroyed now simultaneous simultaneous
with with Thermopylae you had a naval
battle happened in the Strait of our
Artemis ium and once again even though
there was about 600 ships from Persian
ships that were in this battle there was
on the order of about 2 or 300 Greek
ships so the Greeks were once again
outnumbered and they were able to slow
down the Persians but not stop them and
the persons kept having bad luck because
especially with these storms because
even we had this these first ships get
destroyed they sent some 200 ships
around you boliya I'm probably not
pronouncing it perfectly right over here
but then they get destroyed by a storm
so now you have the ships that were that
engaged the Greeks in the street in the
Straits of Artemis IAM the greeks
pullback because they know they're
outnumbered and they essentially go and
retreat or what the persians think our
retreat so the persians followed the
Greek fleet all the way back to the
Strait of Salamis and it's over there
that the Greek fleet is able to because
is able to plan a defeat of the Persian
fleet so you have the Persian fleet gets
destroyed decisively at Salamis you have
the Persian army still in Athens is able
to destroy Athens but the Athenian
people have not been destroyed and so
there's a question for Xerces what to do
at this point this is all now this is
all in 480 BCE and what is our seize
decides to do he says hey I don't want
to get stranded in in in Europe at the
edge of my Empire and so Zeus ease heads
back but he leads
he leaves his some of his ground forces
there and they eventually face a
decisive defeat at Plataea Plataea I
should say right over here and so that
is the last significant threat of the
persians against the greeks from then
they're the greco-persian wars continue
for the next several decades for the
next 20 or 30 years but at that point
it's more of the Greeks on the offensive
and this really is the beginning of the
gross
of the Golden Age of the Greek
civilization